[Music]
the possibility of life outside of earth
is something we've all pondered at one
time or another but whether we've been
visited is another question although
there are endless accounts of sightings
photographs and even reports of
abduction that might suggest that we
have the idea of alien life friendly or
hostile has inspired great works of
science fiction but also a number of
religious movements religions like
realism which state that god was an
alien astronaut who cloned the first
humans and then the more controversial
ones like scientology whose doctrine of
intergalactic warfare and reincarnation
remains the topic of much secrecy and
scrutiny in this video i want to
investigate these so-called ufo
religions where do they come from what
are their beliefs and what do they teach
us about how religions form and spread
welcome to the faith of the future where
spirituality and sci-fi collide
throughout history there have been a
number of unusual reports of
unidentified flying objects frequenting
our skies in 1561 eyewitnesses reported
eerie lights and tube-like rods floating
over the german town of nuremberg this
threw the townsfolk into a panic for
they believed it to be a bad omen from
god even as far away as japan there are
descriptions of an otsuro bune a hollow
ship that washed ashore in 1803 with a
strange woman emerging from the wreckage
according to local legend she was
wearing strange clothes and could not
speak a word of japanese but some of the
oddest encounters might have been
preserved in religious texts a number of
hindu scriptures talk of fantastical
machines known as vimanas in the epic
poem they're a minor they're described
as flying palaces that travel across the
sky within them live gods demons and
heroic warriors in the bible the old
testament book of ezekiel opens with an
otherworldly vision of god's throne
filling up the sky are a collection of
remarkable albeit frightening beings one
of which includes a group of
interlocking wheels covered with eyes
in his book the spaceships of ezekiel
retired nasa engineer joseph blumrich
concludes that this hebrew prophet might
be describing an alien craft but before
we get too carried away it's worth
noting that there are alternative
explanations for these phenomena for
example those strange lights over
nuremberg could be a meteorological
phenomenon known as a sun dog this
happens when the sun's rays are
refracted by atmospheric ice crystals
creating an illusion of multiple lights
in the sky perhaps we're too quick to
pull the alien card stonehenge aliens
the pyramids aliens the nazca lines
aliens often to the frustration of
academic researchers who devote their
lives studying these magnificent albeit
very human creations
now i admit the concept of a ufo
religion might sound a little ridiculous
and over the years it's been relegated
to fringe writers and rogue scholars in
recent decades however this view has
changed to it ufo religions have become
a genuine topic of study you see these
movements give us an insight into how
religions form and how they mature and
spread even if you don't belong to a ufo
religion yourself or are skeptical of
such things a 2010 survey indicated that
10 of americans have had some sort of
ufo sighting in the last 40 years adding
that up has approximately 33 million
people
if ufo sightings are so widespread why
hasn't the study of it become more
mainstream the modern interest in ufos
can be placed on one year 1947 the year
contained two of the most famous ufo
encounters the first was near mount
rainier washington state where american
pilot kenneth arnold claimed to have
spotted nine flying objects traveling at
lightning quick speeds and a few months
later we have the famous roswell
incident where an unidentified aircraft
crashed in the deserts of new mexico
reports later revealed it to be a downed
weather balloon but at the time people
thought it was aliens many still do as
ufo mania grew groups of people began to
come forward claiming to have actually
communicated with extraterrestrial
intelligences people like george van
tassel who was supposedly chatting with
an entity called ashtar who hailed from
the planet venus or george adamski who
was allegedly talking to a blond-haired
race of nordic aliens these individuals
were known as contactees for the
straightforward reason that they were in
contact with celestial beings these
contactees were able to gather a
dedicated following in time new
religious movements were set up around
them like the ministry of universal
wisdom for those who believed in george
van tassel's correspondence with ashtar
since 1953 his followers have met up in
the mojave desert at a place called
giant rock these ufo conventions include
group meditations and prayer in the
hopes of receiving alien communications
from ashtar using donations from his
disciples van tassel even built the
integratron a small white-domed
structure which supposedly was capable
of healing antigravity and even time
travel according to him at least
even if these early ufo religions are a
little wacky and absurd the concept of
extraterrestrial intelligence or even
life in other planets has posed some
serious questions for the many
mainstream world religions many of these
faiths teach that humanity is at the
center of the universe having the
divinely ordained place as stewards of
creation if there are other life forms
out there especially intelligent ones
this means humanity is no longer that
special just one of many civilizations
in the cosmos and what does this mean
for our relationship with the divine is
god quite literally seeing other people
in response to these challenges
religious organizations have actually
developed official stances on the
possibility of aliens and intelligent
life after a long history of downplaying
the importance of science the vatican
has taken a more liberal approach in
recent years in fact in an interview the
pope's chief astronomer yes this is a
real position has welcomed the
possibility of alien life in some ways
it offers an opportunity for the
christian message to reach a wider
audience who knows perhaps christianity
might upgrade from a world religion to
an intergalactic one other religions are
a little more adapted to the idea of
extraterrestrials and alien life in many
buddhist traditions there are already
multiple realms of existence and myriad
life forms out there in the cosmos in
other words there's a chance of being
reborn on another planet
in response to some of the challenges
that these mainstream religions face
several ufo movements have argued that
these faiths were originally the product
of alien encounters this is true for
realism which emerged in the early 1970s
behind this religion is a man called
claude vorallon known to his followers
as rail he proposed the so-called
ancient astronaut hypothesis it's the
idea that the god of the bible was
actually an astronaut from a race of
human-like aliens called the elohim
according to raelian doctrine he cloned
himself to create the first earthlings
adam and eve both were made in his image
and likeness radiance believed that
figures like jesus or the buddha have
been mistaken for humans but are
actually this race of humanoid aliens in
disguise it might seem bizarre for sure
but i guess all religions have their
quirks the bible itself ends with a
vision of humanity living inside a giant
golden cube but you can learn more about
that in my survival guide to the
biblical apocalypse
[Music]
these ufo religions are no strangers to
controversy this is particularly the
case with scientology the most famous
example of a ufo religion even though at
first it has nothing to do with flying
sources based on the teachings of l ron
hubbard scientologists practice a type
of therapy called auditing where
subjects are purged of negative
behaviors through intensely personal
questioning and a device known as an
e-meter this method has not been
recognized by established medical
institutions who state that there is no
grounding in any respectable
psychological practice even in his
lifetime hubbard was prosecuted for
performing this therapy without the
proper licensing it's believed that
hubbard established the church of
scientology to be exempt from these
regulations others believe that he was
inspired by genuine revelation from
above ever since its inception
scientology has garnered a reputation of
being secretive accusations like abusive
practices and charging adherence
extortionate amounts to ascend the ranks
have since come out detractors have even
revealed secrets about the church's
deepest beliefs according to
scientologists doctrine our negative
behaviors are embedded traumatic
memories inherited from past lives that
suffered from an intergalactic war unto
the evil lord xenu the whole backstory
is sprawling epic and complicated and is
reminiscent of the many space operas
that were big in the 1950s despite the
various allegations the church's
scientology is still popular today with
centers to be found in a number of major
world cities there are some high-profile
members of hollywood in the church many
of whom get to travel on hubbard's
private cruise liner the mysterious sea
org
the word cult is often used by
scientology's critics but this is
certainly the case with a group that was
known as heaven's gate it was led by
this man marshall applewhite a
charismatic preacher who claimed to be a
prophet and a witness to the coming
apocalypse recruiting via the internet
in the 90s he taught the humanity did
not have much time left and that there
was a spaceship waiting to save his
followers this spaceship he believed was
the comet hail bop which was close to
the earth at the time this culminated
into a particularly dreadful event in
1997 where 39 members were found to have
ingested a lethal substance naturally
heaven's skate disbanded shortly after
at what point does a religion become a
cult and when does a cult become a
religion is it characterized by coercive
and controlling behavior or a
charismatic leader who exploits their
members or is it simply time and how
long it's been around for
ufo religions carefully straddle these
lines one minute it's a religion and the
next minute it's a cult as mentioned
earlier they provide fascinating
real-life case studies of how religions
form and spread in some ways these ufo
religions aren't so different to the
mainstream faiths both emerge when one
person or group claims to have obtained
secret knowledge from heaven numerous
world mythologies feature soledadies
weather gods and sky fathers these ufo
religions can be seen as a modern
iteration of all this substituting gods
and prophets with aliens in contactees
in some ways it's an attempt to bring
the religion of old into the realm of
modern science or pseudoscience
depending on your perspective
the idea of alien life occupies a
special place in pop culture and our
collective imagination perhaps it's
because it asks some of humanity's most
fundamental questions what does it mean
to be human and what's our place in the
universe for millennia these questions
have kept philosophers religious
thinkers and everyday folks searching
and perhaps we'll never get the answers
that we seek maybe one day we'll stumble
across a lonely satellite sent from
another world
who knows maybe first contact is closer
than we think
hey thanks for watching i really hope
you enjoyed this one ufo religions have
always fascinated me and so i'm really
excited to have made this for you all on
screen now you can see some more of my
videos i cover all sorts of obscure
topics particularly to do with belief
systems and mythology
if you like this video and want to see
more why not subscribe a like and a
comment also go a really long way
anyway i look forward to seeing you next
time
goodbye
[Music]